[Music]
so show of hands who here is running a
monolithic application a big single
piece of software all right and how many
of you have started to split that off
into smaller services okay so that's a
that's a good number of you but there's
still a stable buddy no no that was that
was what was it 50% sick I think half
laughs okay so half have started and
half are ready to see where this goes so
today we're talking about migrating to
micro services in the context of server
lists serverless is a great fit for
building micro services because of how
quickly you can get something started
and launched so here we have a cloud
function it's just a couple lines of
code but it's enough to get a
proof-of-concept going it's not the
complete micro service right there yes
it's not a very smart one it's just
sending some environment variables along
to the requester but that's enough to
integrate with something and see if you
can use micro services with your
application and if you want to deploy it
that is a one-liner a few flags there
for the first time but not very hard so
today we're going to follow that step
and further journeying into the world of
micro services with into the woods
they're an online camping gear store and
they have been doing a lot of great
business investing in their technology
to drive commerce but before we talk
about them too much it's worth knowing
they're an imaginary company they're
going to be an example for us to follow
through their journey and then figure
out which lessons they've learned my
best apply to your own organizations and
since there are monolithic application
they have now is starting to get
technical debt a little fast slowing
down how fast it can build software it's
time for them to start looking into what
else they can do and so one of their
developers tests is going to lead us
into those new approaches it's a shame
they're totally imaginary I really like
that backpack
I'd like to buy that so Tess the
developer she she has this thought about
micro-services could help us with
release velocity and depth velocity now
she needs to study up first
what are these micro services so let's
let's go through some quick definitions
monolith okay that's where most of your
applications you raise your hand
that's what when you have a big ball of
yarn and everything sort of connected or
could be connected to anything else
anything else micro services are when
you have specific services that are
independently built deployed operated
and scaled micro services could take
requests they could potentially call
each other as well to fulfill requests
let's zoom in on one of those micro
services what's inside a micro service
therefore things that we think are very
important there are lots of definitions
out there Adam and I think that there
are four things that set a Microsoft
apart one is it has an API if you're
gonna talk to the March service you talk
to the API no other way in it has some
computer resources so this is a way to
actually run code run business logic
most micro services virtually all will
have some kind of storage database file
system in memory cache something like
that and then the fourth thing is
actually a non-technical thing we think
it's very important that micro service
has a team associated with it as well so
if this service breaks then we know what
team to talk to if this service needs to
be refactored then this team has full
ownership and nobody else can come in
and override what they are doing these
guys are the experts on this micro
service so we're going to follow Tesla's
micro service journey here she's going
to lay the foundation they will build
some brand new functionality as a micro
service after that Tess and team will
take existing functionality in from the
monolith and break that out into a micro
service
the test will sit down and plan with her
boss for the future of what to do
with micro services in the future and
finally there'll be some some
contemplating about what we have learned
here today
so first laying the foundation doing is
this sort of digital transformation
where you break up monolith you change
everything the way all developers are
working at your company also change the
way ops
the ops teams are working requires
that's not a big bang that is like a
hundred small brown bag lunches a lot of
explaining to people who don't know what
these are getting the team on board
after that tests would go and talk to
her manager about I want to go the micro
service route the team thinks we should
go the micro service route she her boss
is Tseng who is the CTO of into the
woods now this conversation can go one
of several ways Tess could go to to
Tseng and say we should break up our
monolith micro services are great what
would Tseng say do we have any CTOs in
the audience oh yeah okay very good I
think you would say CTO there in the
back yeah of course let's do it but
what's the ROI is that right okay very
good so and this is a hard conversation
because we don't have hard numbers as
developers we all feel that micro
services are easier to manage and build
but but it's really hard to prove that's
the case so tests bides her time
a few weeks later Tseng comes to tests
and says hey the business people they
want a new recommendation engine so
based on what's in the cart they should
show recommendations to users now Tess
is in a much better place because she
can say me and the team we have this
great new approach that it will give us
greater dev velocity and for this news a
new feature you want built and now Tseng
is interested so Beth tells me more yeah
it's great that Tess has this
opportunity with a new feature
that might be valuable but isn't
mission-critical immediately because it
it could be faster for her to build this
as part of their existing application
but as a new service it'll take a little
more time to get right but in the long
term maybe we'll be more sustainable
Tess's approach is going to be iterative
using a lean approach of making sure
that at each step of the way through
this they've made the right decisions
and are building the right thing
initially the main concern is will this
particular approach of building
recommendations as a micro service work
on a technical level and furthermore
will it work as a way of having multiple
teams collaborate can the API contract
prevents having a lot more meetings as a
result of having two different software
systems we don't like meetings do we
know and if that works out it's time to
move forward and start to see can this
recommendation system drive some some
money so Tess is using a service
approach in her exploration here and as
we discussed earlier that has a number
of advantages especially for an R&D
effort like this where she doesn't have
the backing of a big ops team and
doesn't have a large pre-established
budget serverless allows a low
infrastructural management solution and
a pay-as-you-go model which means the
experiments they run are the experiments
they pay for there are three main
conserve Alice options on GCP cloud
functions app engine and as you may have
heard this morning cloud run a new
product that allows serverless
containers to be run for now though
cloud function seems like the way to go
this is a very highly scoped
recommendation service and that fits
with the tight focus of a function
here's the architecture of the
recommendation service the monolith is
going to make requests make requests of
the recommendation service sending the
product IDs from the shopping cart and
the recommendation service will send the
recommended product IDs back now for now
for now this is going to be a very
simple system Dave from marketing has a
couple ideas of what they should be
recommending that day and is going to
tell the development team to go ahead
and deploy those recommendations
so these are hard-coded recommendations
more or less yes but the important thing
is that those recommendations eventually
show up on a sharpen car page so there's
always a few challenges from that CTO or
from any kind of technical review
can you really proceed with this will it
work out what if that new service
doesn't respond well as a slightly lower
priority service asynchronous requests
from the monolith where the timeout will
allow it to move on if that service has
an interruption and does not respond
with the recommendation is there a
scaling challenge well a service
approach allows you to scale up
horizontally quite quickly and then back
down again to zero when you're no longer
making recommendation requests and for
set up me and maintenance well
Google engineering is helping you with
that infrastructure challenge so you
don't have to carry a pager for the
networking issues so we're back to the
code shown earlier this is the first
iteration of a recommendation service
and it is deployed and working
successfully so with that as a success
it's time to move on to the next
iteration can they actually drive some
business value by iterating this service
forward and making smarter and more
intelligent recommendations if that
works make it even better and if not
maybe their algorithm isn't working out
so well
only recommending socks all day long
well you do need socks lots of socks for
camping so the architecture that we have
for this this second iteration
might look a little like this this is
probably familiar it's the same API as
we saw on the earlier slide but because
the recommendation service is separated
from the monolith it can change its
implementation and get more intelligent
without the monolith being any the wiser
now instead of test deploying changes
when Dave for marketing makes requests
Dave has access to a Google sheet into
which she can enter the recommendations
using it as a quick and dirty
back-office application instead of tests
and team meeting to write a whole
additional application and data
to pull that off Martin could you show
us what that looks like yeah switch to
the demo please so I am now wearing the
marketing hat I'm Dave in marketing up
here we have the URL for the micro
service the only product in the cart
right now is a map so if we hit the
micro service it returns that if you
have a map in your cart a compass is
recommended that is because dave has
entered if if the requested product is a
map the recommended product is a compass
and if you have more products here so
one product was in the map and another
one could be boots and then we get the
compass and laces so boots leads to
laces now Dave loves this because he can
go in here and say well actually we are
right rebranding our store wouldn't be
cool Dave thinks we should be a nautical
camping store let's send a sextant to
people as a recommendation if they're as
if they bought a map or if they have a
map in their cart so now when we reload
now we see that a sextant is recommended
here this gives marketing great power
they they love how they can edit these
as many times a day as as they feel like
let's have a look at the code for this
switch back to the slides please
so the code to read from a Google sheet
is is quite quite easy first we create
an auth object here as with spreadsheet
scope notice that there is there no
spread of sorry there are no passwords
there are no all ooofff keys there are
no secrets none of that stuff
because test just gave access to for the
service account that this code runs last
she gave she added that service account
as a collaborator on the spreadsheet and
boom all the access
taken care of after that we need to
create a client object and then here is
actually with a call to Google
Spreadsheets is done we need to send two
things along as parameters as the
spreadsheet ID of course that's that
long id looking thing that's up in the
address bar and then the range so what
columns and rows we want to read once
you have that you have a response to
theta dot values object and in this one
you have a two-dimensional array of the
cells from the spreadsheet put a little
set logic and stuff on top of this and
you have the service we just ran and it
clocks in at how many rows lines of code
was it in total less than a hundred
lines especially without the thirty more
for authenticating to a to an API on top
of it yeah nobody likes a variety of
education code so this is a great
success sang he loves it he says to his
tests this is amazing I love this
approach and tests of course she wants
to build on that success and say yes yes
there are many more ways we can use
microservices we still have this big
monolith over here remember now tests
and team they sit down and plan out the
third iteration of the recommendation
engine they are have a few different
things that could do like machine
learning perhaps could drive
recommendations instead of the
spreadsheet they could drive it off of
the current customers previous orders
they could analyze orders in aggregate
there's so many things they could do but
before they have time to build Version
three it's time to break out some logic
from the existing monolith because sand
comes to bethe and says look we are
really having a problem with payments
payments are just not working we're
losing revenue right right and left
could you sprinkle some microservice
magic on payments and make them work
what will bethe say here yes of course
let's do it
this is a great way of getting more
microservices into the company so first
off she
at the exist existing code for payments
and I don't know many of us have worked
in existing code bases and we may have
seen something like this
sprinkled throughout the monolith or
various payment operations that go off
to the external payment provider but
also there are these weird ways where
some squiggly line goes off through some
weird libraries that we think it hits
the payment processor there is also this
odd thing where this is this piece of
code that hits the previous payment
processor we don't think it's being used
but who knows it's checked into source
control there's also this other line off
in a module that's not about payments at
all that goes off to somewhere else and
we're not quite sure where this is the
way existing code bases often look right
it's it's sort of accretes over time and
nobody really knows what's going on in
all places and and nobody dares going in
and delete at all
so Tess she thinks we can really get
some focus here with micro services
let's see how that would be done you
know it seems like one of the biggest
challenges is that payment is really
critical but there's no one who's owning
all those pieces or with a micro service
approach you can at least have one
service in the codebase in the solution
that someone some team can own and make
sure it doesn't start becoming squiggly
so here we only have very straight lines
showing the API calls from the monolith
making requests of the payment service
which does all the interactions with a
payment processor that also has the nice
result of being able to swap out that
payment processor if you want to make a
change and only touch the one service
that API that needs to be thought
through though what exactly are those
various operations this payment service
should support well before getting into
a technical design session we need to be
strategic a technique called event
storming might be used here to figure
out what are all the different kinds of
things that might be long in a payment
service and this requires both the
technical experts and the subject matter
experts to get into the room the
technical experts might know
specific things about the existing
implementation and have a lot of insight
into the internal implementation events
that matter but the domain experts are
going to have a much clearer idea of all
the things haven't been possible to do
so far or might be really important to
do in a year that could be critical to
inform the architecture so once you have
a long list of events that all seem
related to payments it's time to start
separating them out into two piles what
are the events you'll include in your
payment service and what are the events
that you're going to exclude as being
not quite focused enough to belong here
so we might authorize payments charge a
previously authorized payment refunds
cancellations but excluded from that an
inventory function order status and
shipping these are things that might be
intimately related to payments but are a
different domain area with different
owners in different problems
maybe those are micro services for the
next exercise all right so Saeng the CTO
and Tesla's boss he's really encouraged
by this now we actually know what we're
doing with payments what he says there's
one thing missing here there we go
there's one thing missing here today
with a monolith we are dropping some
payments now you're breaking out the
payment service from the monolith which
is great but we could still have this
result this problem that we have with
the monolith today so what if the
monolith sends an authorization request
like authorize this credit-card number
for $100 and somebody put a comma in the
wrong place in the payment service or
the network is down or or the payment
processor is down then a 500 is returned
from the service okay that's good but
we're still in this position where we've
lost money we have a payment that hasn't
been authorized we cannot charge this
payment later how how does your micro
Service magic fix that Tess thinks this
through reads it up on it a little bit
and she comes up with solution
synchronous messaging is the way to go
because instead of just having the
monolith talk directly to the payment
service it can go through cloud tasks
which is a fairly new product in the
Google cloud platform let's see how that
would work
so the monolith would send a message
authorize this credit card for $100 just
like before fire forget needs to do this
once only cloud tasks would then send
that message on to the payment service
somebody put a coma wrong there was a
network error whatever there's a failure
the payment service is well behaved
service it returns a 500 server error
now here things are different start
going different from the previous slide
the cloud tasks component doesn't give
up it will keep resending that until
there's a success and then as soon as a
the status code return from the service
is in the 200s that's how cloud tasks
knows that ok I can lean back I don't
have to send it any more times in Martin
how long will it keep retrying those
those requests yeah you can set it but
at the maximum it can be 30 days and you
can set it to shorter if you want to you
can also adjust the exponential back-off
behavior here ok so Saeng says good good
that that will work and you know I
talked to the ops team they really like
this microservice approach but tests
that those cloud functions we had before
javascript we uploaded them to Google we
didn't really know him where and when
they were running the ops team they want
to be a little more hands-on and have
more control of the stack here how can
we get that with your micro service
approach Tess Tess thinks about it and
says Wow actually they do they want
containers and sang says yes containers
it's exactly what they want but you know
what it's containers is usually a lot of
work we want your that sort of low ops
you've been telling us about that
serverless has what the control of
containers how would they do that it
test doesn't really have time to stand
up a kubernetes cluster today
luckily there's a new solution for this
cloud run a new beta product that
marries the worlds of server lists with
containers you can wrap your service in
a container in a docker file build a
container image and throw it at the
cloud and it will answer HTTP requests
and then if this service were to keep
growing and and the into the woods ops
team wanted to get more heavily involved
cloud one on gke would allow them to
manage that kubernetes cluster and move
those containers over as they deploy
them to the new location
so using cloud run we have all our
requests coming in from the monolith
hitting cloud tasks now as a way to
ensure the resiliency of the system and
then cloud tasks will pace out the pace
out the requests to cloud run which will
then send them onto the payment
processor and store status events in
cloud fire store a unstructured
serverless storage option so what do you
mean when you say server lists for the
database there Adam
you know a lot of database systems
aren't really server lists and
serverless compute systems like cloud
run or cloud functions are going to
scale much higher than a typical single
instance was able to go so that's where
fire store comes in cool it also has
some nice features like eventing on
updates so you might wonder Oh what
kinds of crazy hijinks do I need to get
to in my code to build a cloud service
this is a pretty simple almost hello
worlds like application written ingo
that is going to respond to any request
with payment approved which is how we
all would like payment processors to
authorize our credit cards so there was
no cloud run specific code there that I
could see no there is absolutely none
the the one wrinkle perhaps is that the
port that your HTTP service needs to
bind is going to come in from a port
environment variable which is a little
unusual but it's still flexible and you
can override that as you need to so this
service needs to be wrapped
the dockerfile a dockerfile is a
relatively straightforward packaged
manifest using industry standards around
how containers work via gke or cloud run
and this has two stages a little more
complicated than most docker files but
this has a build stage which is going to
compile our go code into a binary and
then a production stage which pulls from
a stripped-down
variant of Linux called Alpine copy in
that binary and then run it whenever
this container is started up deploying
is two commands here one using cloud
builds to take all this service and
docker file uploaded to cloud built to
have a container image prepared and sent
on to Google to Google container
registry then to deploy G cloud betta
run deploy takes that container puts it
into cloud run and starts you serving I
have found that the first time might be
a little bit slow but most deployments
take about 30 seconds so that's service
ready to go let's start rolling out into
production now as a whole new service
and doing a mission-critical function
you might not want to have it
immediately take overall payment
processing so the monolith is going to
need to be slightly adjusted to send
just some of the traffic to this new
service that means unfortunately going
into all the gnarly old code and making
adjustments there hopefully you've
already got an audit in place to figure
out where all that is so it can be
deleted so they deploy they do this
canary release they send one percent of
the traffic through the new payment
service it works great
they send 5% through the new payment
process payment service it works great
ten percent
they eventually 50 percent they send a
hundred percent through and it's working
no payments are dropped everything
scales beautifully the ops team is happy
because they have containers and the
magic of serverless
they seem to be a very easy rollout but
we all know that there is no such thing
as a trouble-free rollout there is
always something that doesn't go exactly
like you expected in this case Thalia
the controller we've seen her before she
comes into Tessa's office and says hey
all my financial reports are broken this
was a week after they ramped up on
Friday she comes in all my reports are
broken why is that
Tessa starts looking at this closer and
sees that one of the reports actually
has two pieces of data one piece lives
in the monolith and the other piece now
lives in the payment service the and
before when everything lived in the
monolith it was far easier to run these
reports because both pieces of data were
in the monolith how do we fix this this
by the way if you've been working on
migrating to micro-services you will
have seen this problem in one form or
another or if you haven't yet you soon
will this is data fragmentation big
problem especially for reporting so of
course the problem here is we have the
data over here on the far left and on
the right is Thalia whose wants her
report right well it turns out Tess
looks into this and it turns out that
cloud fire store has triggers so
whenever something's written she can
trigger build a new service an ETL
service that is triggered it can
sanitize the data it can do some light
data transformation and then put the
data in a data Lake reporting or
reporting services if you wish the
monolith has an existing reporting
module that one needs to be repointed to
the this data lake so it sends its
transactions and its orders to the data
like now all the data is in the data
Lake reporting service this is kind of
like in the monolith days they probably
ran a separate reporting server this is
the equivalent in in server less land
micro-service land now that all the data
sits in the data Lake they can now
create builder
works off of that so Talia had to go
without her reports for a few days it
was not ideal they had forgotten about
reports when they did the event storming
but they didn't lose any money
Black Friday rolls around now we're
running into a big problem
Tsang goes into tess office and say all
the api calls to the payment processor
are returning quota exceeded errors what
should we do
all hands on deck what is going on this
is something that if you're migrating to
micro-services if you haven't run into
this sort of problem before you soon
will the problem here of course is you
have a chain of components talking to
each other and the they all have
different scaling characteristics so
some of them scale very well and others
not so well for example they may have a
contractual rate limit with a payment
processor you can only send one
transaction a second or something like
that
you might also have seen it if the
component on the far right is a sequel
database that's not server less and
doesn't scale as well you might have
seen it if you connect to an HR system
or a CMS system or other system that
can't handle the kind of load that
serverless can handle what do we do if
you read and check out the literature
you will see lots of thoughts on how to
fix this like you can write all this
code to write a circuit breaker
component or you can implement back
pressure that leads back through the
ripples back through this chain there's
so many things you can do most of them
involve a lot of coding and we all know
if you write a lot of new code to fix
something you might fix it you will also
introduce a lot new of new bugs then
Tess remembers they picked clout tasks
now tasks actually has this knob you can
turn you can adjust the rate so the
monolith can throw any amount of
transactions per second at tasks tasks
will absorb it and then it will only
send out as many to two
run as many assets asked to so Beth goes
in and checks the cloud tasks console
and she sees that oh my gosh we have a
lot of backup tasks here 2,500
transactions are sitting there and
waiting to be authorized or charged as
because they're using cloud tasks they
can go in and change turn that knob and
said max tasks dispatched per second to
one
the default is five that turn it down to
one now all of a sudden there was only
one per second to the payment provider
the payment provider accepts the traffic
and will take after about 45 minutes or
so that will have worked through this
backlog excellent Tess is still a little
shaky shaky shaky shaken up over this
but saying says this is actually a great
job any major transformation any major
migration will have some hiccups along
the way this micro service approach lets
us move faster an experiment born he
loves it death for her part she's just
very happy that this worked out well now
that Tess has been undoubtedly promoted
to chief micro services scientist of
into the woods it's it's time to start
thinking about a more deliberative
approach to how they do micro services
in the future so one lesson that you
might have learned from all this is that
a micro service is a good fit for well
understood problems a user profile
service might be easy for anyone to
understand and anticipate in advance so
maybe that can be created but for harder
challenges for areas that need a lot
more innovation and exploratory
development trying to stay on the path
of a micro service might be might be a
source of slowdowns might get in the way
a little bit so it's important not to
always be too focused on building a
micro service some of the things you
don't yet have a have a mastery of
moving from their Tsang and tests they
might have talked about how many micro
service doing micro services do we want
to have should we have a thousand by the
time we're done with all of this
well fill that out as well move a little
bit more slowly you see them the
trade-off of micro-services is really
between developers and operators or at
least development and operations when
you have a small service it is much
easier for a developer to really get
into all the code and develop an
expertise in it and so when you have
more small services development
complexity might go down but as you add
more and more services and more
interactions between them you start to
gain more operational complexity more
deployments more cascade failure
possibilities and harder troubleshooting
so there's a sweet spot in there that
trade-off is going to be very unique to
every organization because it's very
particular to the people do you have
more senior operations engineers or more
senior application developers between
those two you'll find your sweet spot
now with a serverless approach where
you've taken a lot of that ops overhead
and pushed it on to the cloud that line
for ops complexity will flatten a little
bit and that means your sweet spot can
slide over and it becomes more
reasonable to have a larger number of
micro services in your arsenal
so as they've been adding new micro
services and splitting some off from the
monolith each of those services has a
stake holder this is an owner whether
it's on the business side or otherwise
that understands that service and the
role that technology in the company they
can be a champion of that technology
through the rest of the company but they
can also be an ongoing subject matter
expert for the service
this kind of direct line of ownership
also prevents a lot of confusion about
what priorities are for an individual
service so what did we learn here what
are the what are the lessons test sits
down and thinks carefully about this
this is lessons that we hope you can
apply where you
in your organizations one is Conway's
law this was this was created by Melvin
Conway he brought it down over 50 years
ago
it is as true today as when it was first
written down any of you who has worked
on systems or if you worked on a website
for an organization you've experienced
this what this law is saying is that if
you have a certain type of organization
organizational structure that
organizational structure will lead to
any system that you build will be a
mirror image of that organization you've
seen this when building websites for
companies they will the website
hierarchy and page hierarchy tends to
follow organ or the org chart so if you
have many small teams you will get many
small micro services that means that you
can actually do an inverse conroy
maneuver here if what if you want small
services over there on the right then
you create many small teams if you want
a big monolith you have just one big
room full of developers and everybody's
on the same team next observation is
that weightlifting is really hard if you
do it by yourself but weightlifting
becomes a lot easier if you have like
five or six of your friends to help you
so the monolith is really doing a heavy
lift here before but it's far easier
when the other services are helping out
as a matter of fact the monolith might
doesn't have to lift I do as much work
here because the other services help out
you might even discover that the
monolith is home sick one day and can't
come in and lift weights and the other
services can sort of do the lift and
eventually you might have only services
that's far into the future for into the
woods but it's something to consider and
think about it's also something that we
need to be a little careful when we talk
to the monolith team about we don't talk
about how we're going to shut down their
stuff as a matter of fact this also has
another name that you might have heard
of that was a little too confrontational
for a slide we felt
Martin Fowler calls this the strangler
pattern this is where you have a tree in
the forest and all these vines grow up
around it and suck energy from the tree
and eventually killing the tree and then
all the vines are there but team
weightlifting
let's talk do that instead then you need
an intrapreneur so an intrapreneur
is somebody as an entrepreneur mindset
but works inside an organization
this was Tess in this case you need that
intrapreneur you also need that
opportunity in this case it was the
recommendation engine and that set them
on the path to micro services so you can
be the intrapreneur in your organization
so keep looking for those opportunities
[Music]
you